Kathie's in Jackson Tennessee hi Kathy
how are you hi um hang in there okay how
can I help
well I'm bipolar one and caused a lot of
financial damage and in October of 2012
my husband tried to take his life
because I pushed it really hard and now
we got our income tax backed issue we're
supporting our 33 year old son and so
six year old grandson and we paid off
our like our immediate bills like we had
a bunch of those check advance checks
and stuff and now we paid everything
except for one bill and then we have
like really old credit card debts and
medical bills but we don't were not
paying on them and we're just I don't
know what to do next and my husband is
having a really hard time - so what is
the really hard time regarding now just
trying to figure out where we're going
to go and what we need to do we don't
know you know it's kind of like this
this is actually the best it's been
because I'm taking my medicine correctly
and I'm doing trying really hard to not
spend money and for you look at the
budget and stuff but we just wrote our
first timing check last week in years
and here right now are you both are you
both working
are you both working no he works them on
disability okay I don't have any car
payments you've got a 1987 pickup and I
have a 2005 van okay good well the good
news is is that with your medication and
with good therapy lots of people that
are bipolar are able to live pretty
normalized lives we work with them all
the time because as you can imagine at
doing 25 years of business and financial
coaching I've gotten to meet a lot of
bipolar because when you go manic you
spend money I mean it really creates a
mess and so when people are out of
control with their bipolar it really
shows up in the finances as bad as just
about anything out there so I've gotten
the honestly the pleasure of working
with a lot of folks over the years that
have you know made their life very
manageable and even Victor
aureus fighting through what you're
fighting through so sounds like you're
making good progress I'm proud of you
you got to feel pretty good I do I did
this I'm really working hard and it's
just been you know we're just like where
do we go we're trying to start a savings
account and some people have lent us
money and we're fixed and pay them back
they're both like you know just paste
back whenever they're not worried about
it and except they're really good
friends and stuff and it's like our best
friends and stuff and info we're just
you know well here's what I would tell
you if you guys you and your husband can
sit down and develop a written game plan
every month of where the money that's
going you have disability check coming
in he's got a paycheck coming in we need
to figure out every one of those dollars
give it a give it a name give it a
mission on paper before the month begins
because here's one of the things with
Bipolar and see if this sounds like what
you've been told okay one of the things
that happens is stress activates it yes
and the more you have a plan with your
written gameplan the more you have a
budget and a very much of a routine that
you stay in a routine the cleaner you
stay and the fun part is the cleaner you
stay the less financial problems you're
going to have do to bipolar so it kind
of helps itself helps itself helps
itself right you create a positive cycle
instead of a negative cycle and so the
written budget is just for anyone
handling money it's a big deal for you
it's just mandatory and it'll give him a
sense of hope because any of us
regardless of what we've been through
what we're fighting anybody out there
walking around feels better if we think
we're making progress yes if we can
measure our progress then we know what
we're doing see when the kid gets old
enough in the car that they can watch
the mile markers go down the highway and
they don't how they can look at their
own GPS on their iPhone and they don't
have and they can measure progress then
they don't have to ask you are we there
yet because as adults we walk around
asking all the time in our lives are we
there yet if you don't have something
you're measuring your progress with
it's called a wandering around freaking
lost and it's very stressful so having
the written budget takes the are we
there yet
out of it and it's really going to help
your husband in this situation and for
you
it's just straight-up mandatory kiddo
you ain't got a choice
okay and I'm going to put you two into
Financial Peace University our nine week
class on how to handle money and part of
that is you do a budget every week okay
and I'm going to pay for it oh okay
now here's the last thing when's the
thirty three-year-old moving out we
don't know he has a record and he can't
find a job that that's not a good enough
answer for me this young man needs to
have a life well he needs to have his
dignity back instead of living with his
mommy yeah and so he needs a plan too
and he needs a plan that says with a
record I'm going to get a job I'm going
to start my own business by the way you
can buy a lawnmower if you have a record
yeah and use it on someone else's yard
and they'll pay you dollars it's magical
okay so I'm not working because I have a
record I'm not biting I'm sorry okay so
he needs to get on with his life am i
right we're great okay
so let's help him do that because when
he flies and is free and his it is a
standalone square-shouldered young man
taking care of his own kid that's going
to help his mom and dad with the stress
in the house too isn't it Oh see this
sounds like a magical formula we're
working on I love it okay yeah all right
kiddo you call me back if you need help
okay and I sent you emails all right I
want you to hold on and Kelly's going to
pick up we're gonna get you signed up
for the class and then you call me back
and tell me if you need some help and
I'll help you any time through this but
it's time for you guys to get your get
control of things things have been
controlling you long enough you can do
it you can do it you're already on your
track for you called me I'm proud of you
you